et
[Musique]
nous
quand on dit archéologie les premières
choses qui sont mentionnés par le grand
public sont des vestiges de bâtiments le
colisée le parthénon les pyramides de
gizeh ses titres emblématiques sont des
références absolues qu'elle illustre
bien ce qui pouvait être à l'origine
n'utilisez parfois été restauré en
profondeur voire reconstruit plus les
vestiges sont impressionnants plus il
suscite d'intérêt et c'est normal il
donne à voir les compétences techniques
et artistiques des sociétés antiques une
illustre une forme d'aboutissement de la
connaissance humaine qui plus est
visible dans le paysage un peu mal une
telle richesse et bien sûr l'exception
en archéologie
c'est le résultat des travaux commandité
par les puissants pour marquer des
siècles à venir
l'immense majorité des traces que les
archéologues ont à se mettre sous la
dent est bien plus banal
à l'exception de quelques tombes
richement doté les vestiges enfouis
qu'il faut donc déterré avec patience
sont le plus souvent des objets brisés
céramique et silex par centaines ou
encore des traces ténu de passage d'un
groupe humain une fosse où un feu de
camp
bien moins impressionnants ces vestiges
ont pourtant le mérite de documenter la
vie de la plus grande partie de la
population c'est en quelque sorte
l'archéologie des ploucs pourtant les
ploucs n'ont pas fait que jeter leurs
poulets dans un trou à côté de leur
cabane
ils ont eux aussi laissé leur empreinte
dans le paysage alors pas à la manière
des empereurs ou des pharaons qui
traverse les millénaires mais avec des
choses beaucoup plus discrète
ils sont comme ça les ploucs sont un peu
timides les sociétés humaines qui ont
occupé les territoires depuis la
préhistoire ont en effet modifié le
paysage et l'environnement sans que l'on
puisse s'en rendre compte
à première vue nos campagnes sont en
réalité couverte de vestiges
archéologiques il est possible de
déceler en y prêtant un petit peu
attention
l'exemple le plus simple et le tumulus
protohistorique ou la motte castrale
médiévale que l'on prend très souvent
pour une colline un oeil un tant soit
peu habitué reconnaîtra cependant
rapidement
l'oeuvre de l'humain et non de la nature
mais puisqu'on a choisi de parler des
ploucs
laissons de côté ces deux exemples qui
témoigne encore d'un pouvoir fort pour
nous focaliser sur les éléments attaché
à la vie dans les campagnes
prenons les choses dans l'ordre
chronologiquement on a d'abord commencé
par la prospection pédestre
c'est à dire en marchant et en essayant
de repérer tout ce qui n'avait rien à
faire dans le paysage
sur les littoraux par exemple on trouve
ce qu'on appelle des amas coquille est
en réalité une accumulation de coquilles
vides issus de la consommation de
coquillages par les habitants des côtes
durant des générations
puis les traces des sociétés paysannes
nous sont apparus grâce à la
photographie aérienne technique simple
puisqu'il suffit de survoler les
campagnes à la recherche d'anomalies
visuelle elle nécessite toutefois de
prendre en considération la saison et
leur survol
cette méthode se base en effet sur
l'observation en lumière rasante donc le
matin généralement de la pousse des
végétaux au printemps ça s'y révèle
grâce à la différence de hauteur et de
couleurs des plantes les structures
caché sous la surface
on aperçoit par exemple parfaitement les
fossés ou chemin qui en ayant modifié la
couche de terre facilitent ou empêchent
la croissance végétale sur des zones
très localisées
dernière innovation en date les
archéologues cède aujourd'hui du lidar
c'est en réalité un laser qui depuis un
avion balaye le sol et tentent de
repérer des anomalies à la surface
permettant même de percer à travers les
arbres
le lidar détecte les ruptures subtil
dans le terrain qui témoigne
d'aménagement ancien des habitants des
campagnes bien loin de nos blocages
français les archéologues du cnrs ont
effectué des fouilles au guatemala sur
le site de nash thoune d'ailleurs on
vous a préparé avec la chaîne zeste de
sciences un épisode spécialement sur le
lidar que vous pouvez aller voir juste
après
dans cette vidéo on vous explique plus
en détail cette technique lidar à partir
des résultats des analyses qui restitue
un vaste réseau d'irrigation entre la
cité et les villages alentours pourtant
un touriste lambda ne retient de sa
visite sur ces sites que les vestiges
qui en impose qui s'élève loin de
s'imaginer ce qui se trouve sous ses
pieds nous visitons en fait les sites
archéologiques avec le regard des
citadins que nous sommes devenus en
oubliant que la ville a toujours été
l'exception 99% des humains qui ont vécu
sur la planète étaient des ploucs
ce n'est que depuis 2007 que pour la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité il ya plus d'urbains que de
ruraux dans le monde
toutes les traces de sociétés rurales
passe donc largement inaperçu au profit
les édifices de pouvoir j'avais
d'ailleurs déjà évoqué ce thème dans ma
vidéo sur la disparition des mayas on
les a pensé disparu mais il n'avait fait
que déserté leur ville médiévale les
techniques récentes d'imagerie et le
soin des archéologues pour compiler ses
traces les analyses et nous permettre
enfin de redonner leur place dans
paysage cas ces sociétés rurales
discrète mais essentielle à toutes les
époques
c'est la fin de cet épisode merci
beaucoup de l'avoir regardé je vous
invite donc tout de suite allé regarder
la vidéo sur la chaîne zeste de sciences
je vous mets le lien ici dans le petit
et en barre d'infos c'est une vidéo qui
vous présente de façon très rapide
les résultats des analyses d'un immense
projet qui s'appelle le projet nash
thoune qui a regroupé plein de
chercheurs des archéologues aussi des
géographes du cnrs petites annonces je
vous donne rendez vous ce mardi sur la
chaîne à 21h pour un live que j'organise
pour répondre un petit peu à toutes les
questions que vous me posez ces derniers
temps si vous en avez d'autres des
questions allez-y en commentaire de les
prendre en compte
et puis ce sera aussi l'occasion pour
moi de revenir sur tous les projets qui
ont eu lieu cette année que ce soit le
vortex le livre mais aussi de vous
annoncer les projets à venir parce qu'il
y en a je vous dis à la prochaine salut
[Musique]